[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Today we're
extremely thrilled to have
Ted Slingerland here.
He's a professor, a
member of the faculty
at the University of British
Columbia up in Vancouver.
And his specialty is a study of
philosophy and Chinese thought.
He's a professor of
East Asian Studies
and he also held a
fellowship with the Centers
for the Advanced Study at
the Behavioral Sciences
at Stanford.
And this is, in fact, our
third in an ongoing series
of talks with members
and Fellows from CASBAS.
Without further ado, please join
me in welcoming Ted to Google.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TED SLINGERLAND:
Thanks for having me.
To get a sense of the topic of
this talk, "Trying Not to Try,"
the best way to get a
feel for this paradox
that I'm going to
be talking about
is actually a game at
my local science museum
called Mind Ball.
So the set up is pretty simple.
You have two players at
either end of the table.
There's a little metal
ball between them.
And the goal is just
to push the metal ball
to the other side of the table.
It gets there.
A buzzer goes off, and you win.
So a very simple setup.
The twist is that you're
not using your hands.
You're using your mind.
So I have my head against
an EEG monitor there.
And what that's picking up
is alpha and beta waves.
So alpha and beta
waves are the activity
your brain kicks off when it's
in a rest state, when it's
relaxed, when it's not trying.
The way the game is constructed
is the more alpha and beta
waves you produce, the more
force you exert on the ball.
So the more you relax, the
harder you push the ball.
So the way to win at mind
ball is to not try to win.
You have to actually
out relax your opponent,
and it's incredibly
difficult to do.
The first time I played
I thought I'd do--
I'm a professor of
Chinese philosophy.
I'll do some Zen thing.
I'll be fine.
And I had my eyes closed.
And I could hear--
it makes a noise when the
ball moves back and forward.
It goes, eeh, eeh.
And finally, I couldn't resist.
I opened my eyes.
And I was winning.
The ball was almost at the
other end of the table.
And I thought, oh, I'm winning.
And as soon as I
thought that, the ball
turned around and started
rolling back toward me.
And I started going,
relax, relax, Zen, Zen.
And it didn't work.
So I got crushed by the
person I was playing against.
It's challenging.
What I like about the
game is that it compresses
into the smallest possible
space this paradox of how you
can force yourself to not try.
How can you try
to relax when you
know that the key to
succeeding is relaxation?
How do you use
your conscious mind
to shut your
conscious mind down?
So it's really-- it's
a great way of getting
a sense of the paradox.
Now, this tension,
this mind ball problem,
is something that you
see throughout life.
In certain sub-communities in
our culture are aware of this.
So athletes know that
they're at their best when
they're in the zone,
when they're relaxed.
They're not thinking
about what they're doing.
They're just playing their game.
And they worry a lot about
falling out of the zone.
Because once you fall out, it's
like the mind ball problem.
It's very hard to get
yourself back in again.
Performers-- so people,
musicians, actors--
are also very aware of this.
They know they're at their
best when they're absorbed.
They're not thinking too much
about what they're doing.
And they also worry very
much about the choking,
about falling out of the zone.
So there are certain
sub-communities
who are aware of this,
the power of spontaneity
and the problems involved
with being spontaneous.
But what we don't
recognize, I think,
as widely is that this is a
tension we all experience.
Even if we're not
athletes or performers,
we experience this tension
on a regular basis.
So a good example is insomnia.
So you have an important
meeting the next day.
You know that you need
to be well-rested.
You know that you're tired.
If you could just
shut your mind down,
you know you would fall asleep.
But how do you shut
your mind down?
How do you use your mind
to shut your mind down?
You think about social
situations, so a job interview
or a first date.
The best advice you
can get is relax.
People say that to you, right?
Relax, be yourself.
But how are you going to
relax if faced by this, right?
And in a situation that is
objectively not relaxing,
how do you force yourself
to relax when you need to?
This is the mind ball
problem, or the paradox
of trying not to try.
So you see it
throughout daily life.
We run into it all the time.
We don't tend to talk
about it very much.
So we don't have--
athletes have some words
for it, like the zone.
But we don't tend to talk about
this very much, which is odd.
And I think it's partly
because our culture tends
to focus a lot more on things
like working and trying
and striving.
So our culture focuses on
the opposite of spontaneity,
on effort.
So we send our preschoolers
to Kumon schools
so they can cram and get into
the best elementary schools
and get into the
best high schools.
So they can pop Ritalin and
get into the best colleges.
And then they're going to be
us, constantly multitasking,
constantly on 20
devices at once,
never shutting down the
flow of information.
And even the bedroom
is no refuge anymore.
Most people fall asleep tightly
clutching their smartphones,
sending off that last tweet.
So we're constantly striving.
We're constantly trying.
We get very little downtime,
I think, in our daily lives.
And technology's just
making this worse.
We used to have downtime
built into our lives,
and now we don't anymore.
Now, this would all maybe
be OK if it were the case
that striving always worked.
So if it were the case that
all important goals in life
were things that we could
acquire through striving.
Maybe this is just our fate
to be like Sisyphus, always
pushing this stone
up the mountain.
The problem with that
is that that's not true.
So there are a lot of very
important goals in life that
cannot be attained
through direct striving.
You can't pursue them directly.
So for instance, charisma--
if you're trying to be 007,
you're not going to be 007.
You've got to pull it
off that way, right?
Creativity--
artistic creativity,
intellectual creativity--
is notoriously something
that you can't force.
It's got to come to you.
It's got to come spontaneously.
Something like love of
learning or love in general
is not something you
can force on a kid.
It's got to come from within.
We have a sense that
things like love
have to spontaneously
arise from within somebody.
You can't try to do it.
And if you try to do it,
you're going to ruin it.
Same thing with things
like fun or happiness.
If you pursue it
directly, you crush it.
We've all been at these
parties where hosts
have been saying, have fun.
Let's have fun.
Those are always the
worst parties, right?
If you're trying to have fun,
you're not going to have fun.
So there are a lot of
these goals that just can't
be obtained through striving.
So striving is actually
counterproductive
in these cases.
Why do we not realize this?
And why do we not have language
for the opposite of striving?
We don't tend to have good
words for these things.
I think it's partly the result
of a philosophical hangover.
So we are very much the heirs
of Enlightenment thought,
people like Emmanuel
Kant, Rene Descartes,
who have bequeathed
to us what I'm going
to call the disembodied myth.
So this is this picture that
what we are fundamentally
is minds, disembodied minds.
So we have bodies, but
bodies are just there
to kind of carry us around,
get energy to our minds.
But what we are is
fundamentally minds.
And so that means
the way we obtain
anything worthwhile in this
myth is through rationality,
so using amodal rationality
to think, reason, our way
through dilemmas
or to pursue goals.
Self-control-- so the mind
needs to control the body.
The body has got some
potentially dangerous impulses
that have to be
brought under control.
And it's all about
conscious effort.
So anything worthwhile
in this model
is obtained through conscious
effort in these three things.
Now, the reason I call this the
myth, disembodied myth, is it's
pretty clear that this is
not accurate from a cognitive
scientific perspective.
So the so-called embodied
cognition movement in cognitive
science has been arguing
for a long time--
there's fairly good consensus--
that we're not brains in a vat.
We're not disembodied minds.
We're embodied.
The way in we think
is inextricably
tied up with our embodiment.
So that means that we
think in metaphors.
We think in images.
And these are not
just turns of phrase.
We actually really are
thinking in imagistic terms.
We think with our body.
A lot of our knowledge is tacit.
A lot of our most
important knowledge
is not something
explicit or conscious.
It's something that we've
built into our body,
our bodily knowledge,
essentially.
And this whole body-mind
complex that we are
was designed by evolution
for doing things,
for moving through the
world in an effective way,
not for thinking, not
for abstract thinking.
We're capable of
abstract thinking.
But it's not really
what we're built for.
So we are integrated
mind-body systems.
Now, given that, where did the
disembodied myth come from?
So why did it arise?
Why is it appealing to people?
It must have some appeal because
it's lasted for a long time.
The source of the
disembodied myth,
despite our embodied
nature, is this experience
we do have of being split.
So we often experience a kind
of tension within ourselves.
We say things like, I
had to drag myself out
of bed this morning.
Who's dragging whom, right?
There's only one person there.
Who's in the bed?
Who's doing the dragging?
I had to hold my tongue.
Who are you if not your tongue?
Who's holding what?
It's just a very
strange way to talk.
It seems like metaphors.
But it's not
metaphorical in the sense
that it's reflecting
this tension we feel
between parts of ourselves.
And what I want
to submit is what
we're feeling when
we feel that tension
is a tension between two basic
cognitive systems we have.
So we are integrated
body-mind systems.
But we have two basic
modes of cognition.
And social psychologists,
cognitive scientists
have different
terms for this-- hot
versus cold, system one, system
two, bottom up, top down.
Everybody has their own
favorite terminology,
But basically
they're integrated.
They're designed
to work together.
But they are distinct.
And they're neuro
anatomically distinct.
You can knock one out and
preserve the other one.
So they do seem to
be different systems.
The hot system, system
one, is emotional.
It's fast.
It's frugal.
It's automatic.
And it's mostly unconscious.
So we don't have
typically conscious access
to hot or system-one cognition.
System two, or cold
cognition, is non-emotional.
It's slower.
It's under executive control.
So it's what allows
us to kind of stop
something that's happening and
choose another thing to do,
and it's conscious.
So this is the seat of
our conscious awareness
of ourselves and also
the conscious narrative
we tell about ourselves that
help us understand who we are
and why we're doing
what we're doing.
So I think what
we're feeling when
we feel this kind of
tension is essentially
the body-mind dualism.
This idea that there's a
tension between the two
falls out of the two-system
nature of our minds.
We tend to associate
with system two.
That's us.
So when we have to
drag ourselves out
of bed in the morning,
it's system two
that knows we have an
important meeting that's
struggling with system one,
the bodily systems that
want to stay asleep, that
are enjoying being asleep.
So this explains why
this tension arises,
why it seems intuitive to us.
It also, I think, explains
why trying not to try
is a real paradox.
When I see that metal ball
rolling back toward me
and I say, stop
thinking, relax, the part
of my mind that
I'm using is a part
that needs to be shut down.
The part of mind
that you're accessing
when you are consciously trying
to relax or stop thinking,
you're activating the very thing
that you need to deactivate.
So the two-system
model of the mind
explains why the paradox
is a real paradox.
It is a genuine
cognitive paradox.
You need to get around
it somehow indirectly.
Now, that said it's
a real paradox.
We do need to get
around it somehow.
Because if we want to access
the power of our hot systems,
our embodied cognition,
we need to figure out
ways to get around this
paradox of trying not to try.
And this is where I find
early Chinese philosophy,
my basic specialty,
very helpful.
Because what I sometimes
call the mainstream thinkers
in early China-- the
Taoists and Confusions--
actually embraced an
embodied model of the self.
So they didn't see us
as split fundamentally
between body and mind in
some really strong way.
And they realized
that you needed
to cultivate bodily types
of emotions and intuitions
if you're going to produce
an excellent person, somebody
who's going to be
successful in the world.
Because they had
this embodied model,
they also had some concepts,
some philosophical concepts,
that are not, I think,
very well known in the West
but I think are helpful
for us to learn about.
So one of these is
this idea of wu-wei.
It literally means "no
doing" or "no trying."
I like to translate it
as "effortless action,"
because you're often
very active when
you're in a state of wu-wei.
It's a state where it's a
lot like being in the zone
as an athlete.
You lose a sense of
yourself as an agent.
You lose a sense of effort.
You don't feel like
you're exerting effort,
and yet everything
works out perfectly.
You're successful.
Everything's going the
way you want it to go.
One of the best
illustrations of wu-wei
is a story in this Taoist text,
"The Zhuangzi" about Butcher
Ding.
So he's cutting up
this ox in what's
probably a very important
public ceremony.
So there's a huge
crowd watching him.
And he's got to cut up
this enormous animal,
and he just kind of
waves his cleaver,
and the ox falls apart.
And it's like he's dancing or
performing classical music.
And the ruler who's
watching him do
this says, how did you do that?
That was amazing.
And the butcher says, well,
I don't have any skill.
I don't know what I did.
I didn't really do anything.
But then he's pressed on
it, and he says, well,
what I do is I shut down.
Essentially, I shut
down my cold cognition.
I shut down my mind.
I shut down my perception.
And as he puts it, I
let my spirit guide me.
He says, I let my
spiritual desires guide me,
and they guide me through
the spaces in the ox
in between the bones
and the ligaments.
I never touch anything.
I'm just moving in
the spaces in between.
And it's pretty clear
this is supposed
to be a metaphor for our lives.
We're supposed to live our
lives like the cleaver going
through the ox.
So what's interesting about
this is he's talking about,
I think, essentially
hot cognition
as a force within him.
So in the early Chinese world
view, this thing, this spirit,
is implanted in the
Zhuangzian view, at least,
implanted in us by heaven,
the supreme high god heaven.
And it's something
that can guide us.
If we can loosen the
hold of the mind upon us,
it's something
that can guide us.
I think from a contemporary
perspective the best way
to think about it is that he
shut down his cold cognition.
And he's allowing his
trained hot cognition,
so not just what he's
born with but something
he's trained up
over a long period,
to take over and do its work
without the interference
of the conscious mind.
Another analogy or helpful
way to think about this
that I use with my
students sometimes
is the "Star Wars" example.
So the end of the first
"Star Wars" movie, at least
the first for us older
people, Luke Skywalker
is going to blow
up the Death Star.
He's got to fly down this
trench with his photon torpedoes
in this very small opening.
And he turns on his
targeting computer,
and he hears in his head
Obiwan's voice, right?
He said, Luke, use the force.
And he shuts off his
targeting computer.
And everyone back at Rebel Base
is like, what are you doing?
You turned off your
targeting computer!
He says, don't worry about it.
And he taps into the force.
He fires his torpedoes.
They go into the little vent
and blows up the Death Star.
And he returns back to
the Rebel Base triumphant,
a very romantic reunion
with Princess Leia.
It was romantic back then.
It's kind of creepy now.
We didn't know about the
whole brother-sister thing
when I was little.
But what I like
about this is it's
the same basic idea, right?
The targeting computer's
cold cognition, right?
You're shutting down
your conscious mind,
your perception,
and you're tapping
into some deeper, bigger
force that's going
to guide you the right way.
What's interesting,
too, and very few people
realize this is is there's a
direct historical connection
between Butcher Ding
and Luke Skywalker.
So "The Zhuangzi" are this text.
"The Zhuangzi" is an
early Taoist text,
pre-Buddhist Taoist text.
It becomes the main influence
in Chan Buddhism, an early form
of Chinese Buddhism.
Chan Buddhism goes to
Japan, becomes Zen Buddhism.
Zen's the Japanese pronunciation
of the same character.
Zen Buddhism becomes one
of the two main components
in the Bushido Ideal,
the ideal of the samurai.
The ideal of the samurai
becomes a huge influence
on the films of Kurosawa.
And George Lucas in
several interviews
has said that he was
inspired by the samurai ideal
when he was thinking
about the Jedi knights.
So there's actually a
direct-- it's very torturous,
but there's a direct historical
connection between that Butcher
Ding story and Luke Skywalker.
You basically swap the
cleaver out for a lightsaber,
and it's the same basic idea.
You're surrendering
conscious control
to this force within
you that's more
powerful than the
small conscious self.
Another helpful way
to think about this,
another contemporary
concept that's helpful,
is this idea of flow.
So a lot of people have heard of
Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi's idea
of flow.
And it shares a lot of
the phenomenological,
or kind of from the inside
feel features of wu-wei.
So you lose a sense of
yourself as an agent.
You lose a sense of
the passage of time.
You are successful, and you
don't feel like you're actually
doing anything.
For Csikszentmihalyi,
though, for him,
the crucial thing about flow
is complexity and challenge.
So he says he wants
to distinguish flow
from other states,
like zoning out
in front of the TV eating
Doritos, where you lose
the sense of passage of time.
But you emerge from that
feeling dirty and bored
and not energized.
What's special about
flow, he thinks,
is it's you're in
this flow channel,
the perfect combination
of your skill
and the challenge
of the situation.
So if it's too challenging,
you get anxious or frustrated.
If it's too easy, you get bored.
So you've got to be
in that perfect match
between your skill
and the situation.
And that means that you've got
to be constantly ramping up
both of those things.
So as you get better
at the activity,
you've got to ramp
up the challenges,
or you're going to fall out of
the flow channel into boredom.
So for him, it's
about-- he talks
about this ever-spiraling
challenge and complexity.
Now, this fits certain
types of situations
that we'd call flow, or
wu-wei, so high-stakes rock
climbing, competitive tennis.
There's a lot-- kayaking
this fits as well.
The problem is it
doesn't actually
fit Csikszentmihalyi's
own survey data.
So Csikszentmihalyi's
survey data--
he's now done decades of
this, he and his colleagues--
have shown that most
people report flow
in situations like
walking in a landscape
that they've been
in a hundred times
and they know really
well on a level path.
There's no ropes
or chains involved.
There's nothing challenging.
They're just walking, but they
feel like they're in flow.
Another very common
place people report
flow is social situations,
hanging out with kids
or hanging out with
family members or friends
over a meal--
again, very low challenge,
very low complexity.
So there's something
his definition
of what we'd want to call flow
or wu-wei is missing something.
And I think this is
where wu-wei is actually
a more helpful concept.
It's actually a bigger
umbrella concept.
So for the early Chinese what
defines wu-wei, what sets it
apart from other states, is
being absorbed in something
larger than yourself.
So you're part of something
that's bigger than yourself.
Something else is kind
of taking over in a way.
And crucially, it's
something that you value.
So it's a bigger whole that
as philosophers would say
is normatively positive.
You value it as
something important.
It doesn't have to
be life-shaking.
It could just be something
that you care about doing well.
But something bigger
than you that you value
is what induces wu-wei.
That's how you get
into this state.
Now, for the early Chinese
this was a theological concept.
And so for them the larger whole
was this metaphysical order
to the universe.
It was the Tao, so The
Way, The Cosmic Way.
So you're in a
state of wu-wei when
you can get in
touch with the Tao
and let the Tao carry you along.
For contemporary
people who don't
share the early
Chinese world view,
it's got to be other stuff.
It can't be this thing.
It could be,
though, theological.
So for people who are
traditionally religious,
they often get into a flow,
wu-wei, state in situations
where they're worshipping
with other people.
So it could be a
theological idea.
I think more
typically, again, we
get into it in
everyday situations
where we're enjoying
the people we're with.
We're enjoying taking
care of small children.
We get into wu-wei,
or flow, in landscapes
that we value that we love.
There are certain
landscapes, like Point Reyes,
that put me instantly
into a state of wu-wei.
Activities that we like,
so cooking, whatever
your hobbies are
that you care about,
especially typically ones that
you share with other people,
there's a strong social
component to wu-wei.
So there's a variety of ways.
And as modern people we tend--
often these different larger
wholes are not connected in
any kind of coherent way.
There's no story you
could tell that explains
why you like cooking and
Point Reyes and kayaking.
But they fit
together in your mind
in some way that's
hard to articulate.
And the key thing is that they
all put you into this state.
So that's the first of the
concepts I want to introduce,
this idea of wu-wei.
The second is this idea.
Unfortunately, in
modern Mandarin
it's pronounced "duh," which
always makes my students
giggle.
It's sometimes translated as
"Virtue" with a capital V.
But I prefer something more
like charismatic power.
This is a power--
it's a kind of aura
that you kick off when
you're in a state of wu-wei.
So if you're in
wu-wei, you emanate de.
And so this is the thing
that as a Confucian ruler
allows you to cause people to
follow you without coercion.
You don't have to
make them follow you.
They just flock to you,
and they want to obey you.
If you're a Taoist,
it's what allows
you to move among
people and even animals
without being harmed.
Everyone's kind of
relaxed around you.
So it's this very crucial power.
It explains especially
the social success
of people who are in
a state of wu-wei.
Now, again, for
the early Chinese
the connection is explained
in theological terms.
So when you're in
a state of wu-wei,
you're in harmony with heaven.
Heaven likes you because
you're doing what heaven wants.
And so heaven gives
you this power
as a way-- it's kind of like a
star on your forehead saying,
this person's OK.
Follow what they say,
or don't hurt them.
So it's connected theologically.
I think, again, we could
tell a kind of modern updated
naturalized version
of this story,
where we see the connection
between wu-wei and de
in cognitive terms, in
cognitive scientific terms.
But doing this is going to be
a little bit more complicated
than the wu-wei story alone.
And we have to go all the
way back to the Pleistocene
to explain this.
So human beings have spent most
of our evolutionary history
in small hunter-gatherer
bands, just like our primate
ancestors-- so bands
where we were related to
or we knew most of the people
we were interacting with.
And then in an evolutionary
blink of an eye--
I mean, agriculture
was super recent
if you have a longtime view
on the level of species--
we start living in these
large-scale societies.
So agricultural societies
where we're interacting with
strangers all the time.
We're having to coordinate
with massive numbers of people
way beyond what we ever had to
do in our evolutionary history.
And it's a very
successful strategy.
So 99.9% of people
living today are
living in large-scale societies
of one kind or another.
It's a very successful strategy.
There's a bit of a mystery
about how we pull it off.
Because going from a
small-scale village
or a hunter-gatherer life
to large-scale societies
involves various
cooperation dilemmas
that we're not equipped
biologically to deal with.
We haven't had time to evolve
to deal with these things.
So there's got to be some
kind of new mechanisms going
on that help us get through some
of these cooperation dilemmas.
There's a variety of them.
The one that I
want to focus on is
one identified by the Cornell
economist, Robert Frank.
So he's talked a lot about this
idea of the emotions as having
a kind of rational function
in human cooperation dilemmas,
and particularly in
dilemmas that he talks about
as commitment dilemmas.
So these are situations
where you have a cooperation
situation that
can only be solved
by some kind of emotional
commitment between people.
The classic example is
the prisoner's dilemma.
And actually, right now at the
Exploratorium in San Francisco
they have an exhibit
on social cognition
and that you can do
the prisoner's dilemma.
You can play it in
various iterations.
So it's fun.
I'd recommend
seeing this display.
The classic set up in
the prisoner's dilemma,
you have two prisoners that
are being held separately.
They've done something.
They've done a crime.
They're guilty.
And yet the DA doesn't
have enough evidence.
He doesn't have a very
good case against them.
And so they are offered a deal.
So one thing they could do
is if they both just shut up,
they'll get very
little jail time.
They'll both go to
jail for a month,
because they don't have a
very good case against them.
But they're being
offered a deal where
if they rat on the other
person, they get off scot-free.
Then the other person has to
go to jail for a full year.
That's the deal
that's being offered.
Now, the problem in the
prisoner's dilemma--
they're being held separately.
They can't communicate.
Even if they could
communicate, they'd
have no way to enforce any
kind of agreement they came to.
The only rational decision
in prisoner's dilemmas
is to confess and betray, to
defect, as economists say.
And so what a purely rational
being is going to get--
so they end up both
confessing and betraying
and get three months in jail,
which is better than a year.
That's why you have to
do it if you're rational.
But it's not great.
It'd be better to just
do one month in jail.
Purely rational
beings are always
going to lose in the
prisoner's dilemma.
They're always going to
get a suboptimal outcome
in the prisoner's dilemma.
What's interesting is
that human beings--
Vulcans can't solve
the prisoner's dilemma.
Humans can.
And the way humans do
it-- so we often solve
prisoner's dilemmas, and
there's multiple forms of this
in everyday life--
through things like
trust or honor.
So why do gang members
not betray each other?
Because they have honor.
They're not going to betray
their fellow gang member.
These are emotions.
And the emotions are basically--
this is Frank's argument.
I think he's right about this.
The emotions are pre-binding us.
They're forcing us into honoring
an agreement, even when it
becomes not rational
to honor it,
when it becomes against our
self-interest to honor it.
One way to think
of this, I think,
that's helpful as
the myth of Odysseus.
So he knows that when he sails--
he wants to hear
the Sirens, but he
knows the future
Odysseus is not going
to be able to resist the Sirens
when he hears the Siren call.
So he has his sailors
tie him to the mast
and put wax in their ears so
they don't hear the sirens.
He's bound himself.
Odysseus won.
Odysseus in the present is
now making Odysseus two--
is forcing his decision
in a way that Odysseus two
has no choice over anymore.
He's pre-binding himself.
This is what emotions do for us.
Emotions like honor
and loyalty and love
bind us to cooperation dyads
or triads or larger groups
in a way that's
immune to defection
because we've now
bound ourselves.
So that's the power
of commitments.
So emotional commitments are
crucial for human beings.
These type of dilemmas arise
all the time in human life.
There's a problem
with these though.
There's an issue with
emotional commitments.
And that's really
the best strategy,
if you have commitment
things going on,
is to be able to
fake commitments.
It's to have your sailors
tie you to the mast,
but it's not tied very tightly.
You can get out of
it if you want to.
That would be ideal.
So there's going
to be pressure on
people to cheat, to
fake commitments,
because then they get all the
benefits of the commitment
interaction without
paying any of the costs.
And you're going to also expect
a kind of evolutionary arms
race, where people are going to
get better at detecting people
who are faking commitments.
You're going to expect
this to get ramped up.
And so the worry in commitment
interactions is hypocrisy,
so people faking the
commitment to get the benefits.
The solution, or at
least partial solution,
involves signaling
of various kinds.
And so this idea of signaling,
one of the most helpful ways
to think of it is in
the non-human animal
world-- costly signaling.
So this is an idea
that developed
when people were trying to
explain things like gazelles.
So when a gazelle is approached
on the savanna by a predator,
instead of running away
right away, it stops.
It just jumps up
and down in place.
It's the weirdest
thing you've ever seen.
You're just like, what's
the matter with you?
There's a lion, run!
But they don't.
And the argument in it, and
it seems to be the case,
is that this is a signal.
The gazelle is saying
look how high I can jump.
Don't try to chase me,
because you won't catch me.
And you'll waste time.
I'll waste time.
So why don't you go
find a weaker gazelle
who can't stot like I can.
And I'm going to keep eating
my grass and win-win situation.
And this really seems
to be what happens.
The lion's like,
yeah, you're right.
I can't catch you.
And they go off and
find another gazelle.
Everyone wins.
It only works, though, because
it's inherently unfakable.
If you didn't have strong
legs, you couldn't stot.
You couldn't jump that high.
So there are these kind of
unfakable signals in the animal
world.
In human beings, there's
a kind of equivalent
in these relatively
unfakable signals
that we kick off in emotional
displays and facial displays.
So the classic
example is-- these
must have been
European researchers.
So here's the pan-American
smile, the superficial way
Americans smile.
This is a system two smile.
This is consciously willed.
You're using your conscious
mind to make this smile.
This is the so-called
Duchenne smile.
That's a sincere smile.
That's hot cognition.
It's different muscle
systems in the face,
and they're run by
the different systems.
One's run by system two.
One's run by system one.
So what we're looking for when
we're evaluating someone who
says that they're loyal, who
says that they honor the gang,
and they always want to
be a member of our gang,
we want to see this.
We want to see something
like the Duchenne smile.
We want to see a facial
expression that reflects
a lack of cognitive effort.
So we trust and we tend
to willingly engage
in commitment situations with
people who are not kicking off
signs of cognitive control.
So I think that's the kind of
signaling that human beings do
with one another.
And I think this explains
the connection between trust
and spontaneity, basically
between wu-wei and de,
is that when we see people
who seem to be sincere--
they don't seem to
be making effort--
we like them.
We trust them.
We want to follow them.
We wish they would run
for president, right?
This is basically human beings
using the mind ball paradox
as a social signal.
We're taking
advantage of the fact
that you can't force
spontaneity to use it
as a relatively honest signal.
At least unless someone's
a really good faker,
we're going to use it
as an honest signal.
And this then explains the
connection between wu-wei
and de in a naturalistic way.
You don't have to tell
the story about heaven
giving to you as a power.
It's that we trust people
who are not kicking off
signs of cognitive control.
And there's a whole
bunch of evidence--
I only got some of
it in the book--
that people who are
spontaneous behave properly.
They cooperate better.
And as soon as you give
people time to think,
then they start cheating.
They start getting more selfish.
The default strategy
for most people
in large-scale societies,
at least, is to cooperate.
So I think this is one way
that Chinese philosophy can
be very helpful.
We have this connection between
these ideas in early China
that are explained theologically
but actually points
in directions of new research.
So there hasn't
been a lot of work
on this, the role of
trust and commitment
and spontaneity and
human collaboration.
It's now starting to
get off the ground.
But this can be very helpful.
There are new ideas that can
help us understand things
in our own world, like how a
short-fingered vulgarian could
defeat a vastly more qualified
and dignified opponent.
He's got de.
It's evil de.
You can have evil de.
This is where I think
the Chinese are wrong.
She completely lacks it.
She's wooden.
She lacks that kind of sense.
People don't trust
her because she's
kicking off signs of
cognitive control constantly.
I think if you look at
videos of the two of them,
that's what it comes down to.
People trust him because
he's spontaneous.
He's spontaneously evil,
but he's spontaneous.
People like it.
So that's one way these
ideas can be helpful.
They explain things in
our contemporary world
that otherwise seem baffling.
Another way early Chinese
thought can be helpful
is they worried about
something like the mind ball
paradox a lot.
They all wanted to get
into a state of wu-wei.
So they developed
these techniques
for getting around the
paradox that are actually
quite sophisticated.
So I walk through
these in the book.
There's the Confucius carving
and polishing strategies.
So basically, try really
hard for a long time,
then the trying will
fall away, and you'll
able to be spontaneous.
There's the Laozian stop trying.
Go back to nature.
Be like that unhewn wood.
Get back in touch
with your real nature.
That'll allow you
to be spontaneous.
There's the Mencian
strategy that kind of
splits the difference.
We've got the beginnings
of proper wu-wei within us,
but they're not strong enough.
We need to cultivate
them, help them along.
But we can't force it too much.
We've got to just be like a
patient farmer cultivating
sprouts.
And then there's the
Zhuangzian forget about trying.
Forget about not trying.
Just let go, and
everything will be OK.
The spirit will take
over, and you'll be fine.
So you have these
different strategies.
None of them works
in a 100% way, right?
Because it's a real paradox.
If one of these
strategies worked,
it wouldn't be a paradox.
But each of them
is a helpful way
to try to get
around the paradox,
in the same way people have
strategies like counting sheep
or whatever when you're
trying to get to sleep.
You've got to fake yourself out
to get into a state of wu-wei.
Which of these strategies
is the most helpful
probably depends
on the situation--
so the details of the
barriers to spontaneity
that you're facing.
Life stage-- so carving
and polishing is, I think,
clearly more important
when you're younger.
You just don't have the properly
trained hot cognition yet
to trust your hot cognition.
And probably
personality type-- so
what's appropriate
for an introvert
may not be appropriate
for an extrovert.
There may be kind of
innate differences
in which strategy works
the best for people.
But I think there's something
very helpful about having
at your disposal a toolbox of
different strategies that you
can pick from depending
upon the situation.
So I think that's
an important thing.
Another important thing is
just having these words,
expanding our vocabulary.
So I've found that people
who know me or read my work
start using wu-wei all the time.
You're not being very
wu-wei about this.
Why don't you try to be
a little more wu-wei.
Come on, man.
She has no de.
I said this to people watching
tapes of Hillary Clinton
deliver speeches.
Like, that woman has no de.
People start using these terms.
And I think what this reflects
is a cognitive conceptual gap
in the English language,
so in the same way
that we adopted the words
schadenfreude from German
because we feel schadenfreude.
We just didn't
have a word for it.
Words matter.
Words help us focus on
aspects of existence
that we maybe don't pay
enough attention to because we
don't have a word for it.
We don't necessarily identify
it and single it out.
So I think that's helpful.
Another helpful thing is
just the role of trust.
So we tend to focus, I
think, too much on contracts
and explicit
agreements and rules
and miss the fact that
most human interactions,
whether in the workspace
or in larger society,
are about commitments.
So looking at the
spontaneity trust connection
makes you think
more about the fact
that human interactions
are about commitments
and not contracts.
It's about emotional
ties people have.
So that's another helpful thing.
Specific policy things--
don't underestimate
the power of alcohol.
So this is going to be
the next book topic.
But alcohol is a very fast way
to deactivate your system two,
at least temporarily.
I think that in the
workplace right now
you have a problem where people
are having dry holiday parties
and discouraging people from
going out drinking after work.
And what they're worried
about is that, right?
That can happen
at office parties.
So they're weighing the
potential for this kind
of disaster against what?
People having fun.
So it seems like the
math is a no-brainer.
You just don't do it.
I think they're
missing the point
that when you don't give
people this cultural tool--
it's a cultural tool
we've developed--
you make them less able to form
commitment ties to one another.
So there's something
about human beings
for millennia have been
poisoning themselves, taking
perfectly good foodstuffs
and turning them
into poison for some reason.
And it's because it helps people
get past cooperation dilemmas
by temporarily
down-regulating our defenses,
our cognitive control.
So I think that
when we shake hands,
when you shake
hands with someone,
you're basically saying,
look, I don't have
a weapon in my dominant hand.
So I'm not trying to
fool you or hurt you.
Do a couple of
shots with someone,
you're basically taking
your prefrontal cortex out
and putting it on
the table and saying,
like, no cognitive control.
So what I say is
really what I think.
You can trust me.
And this is the reason why
when Skype was invented
everyone was like,
oh, well, people
will stop traveling for
work, because why would you
fly to Shanghai if you can
Skype with people there?
People still fly to Shanghai.
And that's because people don't
trust other people unless they
sit in a room with them
and typically share a meal
and typically get a little
bit wasted with them.
Because there's a sense
that when you see someone
in that kind of context,
you get a-- and also
you're reading body signals.
You're getting all this
incredibly thick bandwidth
of information and
person that you don't
get over Skype or the phone.
So that's an important insight.
And so the Chinese sometimes
used drunkenness as a metaphor
for wu-wei.
There's something to that.
It's a shortcut to
down-regulating your mind.
And there is some
evidence also of-- there's
this idea that artists have
long had about the muse,
that intoxication causes
creativity to happen.
And there's some
evidence for that.
So you get people
mildly drunk in the lab,
and they do better
at creativity tasks.
You can't get them too drunk.
Then they get bad again.
But there's a sweet spot
where they're really good.
I presented on this years ago.
And the book came out of
the Google campus in Irvine.
And the first person to raise
their hand was Balmer Peak.
So I looked into
the Balmer Peak.
Apparently there's a very narrow
blood alcohol concentration
where you guys
code a lot better.
That's the theory.
Afterwards they took me
to their wall of-- they
have a room of
scotch down there.
I don't know if you
guys are that cool.
But they have a real
amazing room of scotch.
And I think what's interesting
about that is you see, I think,
places like Google have realized
that if your business model is
predicated on
creativity and making
breakthroughs and
figuring stuff out,
making people just sit
in front of the screen
for a certain number
of hours a day
is not going to get you that.
The striving, striving,
striving doesn't work.
And so these guys told me.
They said, when we're
facing a conceptual problem,
we go to the scotch room and
have a little bit of scotch.
And then we play some ping pong.
And then eventually
we figure things out.
You need to create space
for creativity to happen.
You can't force
creativity directly
by chaining someone to a
desk until they come up
with an idea.
So that's important-- workplace
design and work culture.
And at the most abstract
level, embodied cognition--
so if you take things
like wu-wei seriously,
you take seriously
the fact that we
have embodied ways of being
in the world that are very
powerful and very important.
Abstract knowledge
alone is not enough.
You can have abstract knowledge
and not be good at things.
You need to train imagination.
So when you educate
kids, you need
to train them how to problem
solve and how to think,
not just a set of
facts about the world.
And I think this
is something we're
terrible at right now is
you've got to create space
for your unconscious
to do its work,
for your body to do its work.
So right now we
bombard ourselves
with constant information.
We never have time to actually
integrate the information
that we already have.
So you need to create
space for wu-wei to happen.
You have to go for
walks in the mountains.
You have to let your
mind wander a little bit.
You could do this through
physical activity, so
things that distract
your mind from itself
because you're doing
something with your body.
And also, I think crucially,
you've got to sleep.
So those people who
are striving-oriented
tend to view sleep as just
this horrible waste of time.
How can we minimize
that wasted time?
It's not wasted time.
When you're sleeping,
you're doing important work.
You're pruning
neural connections.
You're integrating the knowledge
you acquired during the day.
It's a very good
example of something
that looks like
you're doing nothing,
but you're doing a lot.
And people who don't
get enough sleep just
don't have a good
enough integration
of the knowledge they've been
acquiring during the day.
So we need to build more
space into our lives
in a way we don't
have enough, I think.
So when the book came
out, it was originally
marketed as a self-help book,
which I advised against.
And what happened is
exactly what I predicted.
People who bought it
as a self-help book
were pissed off,
because they thought
there'd be 10 steps
to being a Zen master.
And they could just follow
the 10 steps and be fine.
The fortune cookie's empty.
The early Chinese don't have
any kind of magic formula
for how to attain wu-wei.
So it's not helpful directly
in that kind of self-helpy way.
Where it is, I think, helpful
is by focusing our attention
on the importance of embodied
cognition, the imagination,
the importance of trusting our
body in certain situations,
and crucially, also getting us
to see how this spontaneity is
linked to trust and how
spontaneity is really
at the center of human success
in a lot of areas of our lives.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So in this era of
quantified segmented cells,
where every moment,
every breath has
to be justified, and time
cards, and we are quantifying
ourselves in so many ways--
number of steps, the number of
breaths, number of heartbeats,
all of that.
It really seems
completely counter
to this idea of flow and
trust and unquantified cells
where creativity can bloom.
So in fact, it sounds like
we are poisoning ourselves
with all this quantification.
What do you think?
TED SLINGERLAND: Yeah,
no, I totally agree.
This is one of the
problems is that we
don't build in enough
time for these things.
And technology
has made it worse.
So when I was a
student, you always
had-- like you had
enforced downtime.
At the very least, when
you're walking from one class
to another, there's
nothing else you
can do except look at
the squirrels running
around the trees and
let your mind wander.
Now I look at my students, and
they're constantly plugged in
somehow or answering texts.
They never actually are
not taking in information.
And I think that's
really troubling.
I think it's going to--
and it's going to have
effects down the line
in terms of people's
ability to really have
creative breakthroughs.
So I think smart
companies actually
are aware that you need to give
people some unstructured time
and create ways for
them to interact in ways
that aren't being quantified.
What did we accomplish
in this meeting?
It's not clear.
But we drank some
good scotch and we
played some good foosball.
And maybe like next
week, we're going
to have some benefit from that.
But it's hard to predict.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much for this talk.
And I'm Chinese.
I'm so proud of you bringing
so many Chinese culture
to your book.
And I just finished a book
"Thinking Fast and Slow."
And it does say that when
we do a lot of things,
we should use our
system two, right?
But here you talk about wu-wei.
That seems a conflict of ideas.
And especially when
we do investment,
we should be reasonable.
So do you think that wu-wei can
contribute to the investment?
TED SLINGERLAND: Yeah.
Oh, to the investment?
Yeah, that's a good question.
So that's an important point.
So Kahneman's book, which
I flashed briefly up there,
"Thinking Fast and
Slow," the work
that he's done on
two-system thought
is how system one's
dangerous, and you
need to guard against system
one and actually use system two.
And the situations-- and
he's right about that.
We're subject to all
these kind of errors
of thinking when we're
trusting our system one,
and that really has
to do with a mismatch
between our evolved
cognition and the structure
of modern life.
We're just not built to
reason about investment.
We're not built to reason
about climate change, right?
Climate change is
such a big thing.
We just don't deal with
causality well intuitively
on that level.
And that's where we either
have to use system two.
And system two-- so
I've been emphasizing
that the power of system
one partly as a corrective.
Obviously, system
two is crucial.
There's a reason we evolved it.
It's super expensive
physiologically.
So we wouldn't have it if
it wasn't really important.
So in situations like
climate change, investment,
you either need to switch into
system two to do it right.
And Kahneman's
focused most on that,
on correcting your intuitions.
Or you need to figure
out a way to make
your system one do the things
that system two wants it to do.
And so that's where I
think things like Al Gore
doesn't just give you the stats.
He shows you a polar bear
drowning in the Arctic
because there's no more ice.
You've got to make the--
you can take system two
insights and build them
into your system one.
And that's actually it.
So the Confucian and
self-cultivation strategy
is interesting,
because the model
seems to be they have these
insights using cold cognition.
It's not what they're born with.
So for instance, Xunzi, this
late Warring States Confucian,
he's got this passage where he
talks about where did ritual--
and by this he really means
all of Confucian culture--
where did it come from?
And he says the sage king
saw the state of nature.
People were fighting
with each other.
It was too chaotic.
And he hated it.
And so they seemed to then
switch into system two
cognition and say,
what would be the best
way to distribute
resources in a society?
And so they're
using cold cognition
and what seems to be
utilitarian reasoning.
But Western philosophers
would then stop there.
And then they would say,
let's teach everyone
how to reason using
utilitarianism.
But they don't.
They say, OK, now let's design
rituals and music and things
that will take that cold
insight and build it
into people's hot cognition so
they can really actually do it
reliably.
So that's the other--
so to get around
the limitations
of our system one
is either to switch
purely into system
two, which probably is
appropriate in some situations,
or to use system two
insights to transform.
Because system one is fungible.
You can change it.
That's how skill
acquisition happens, right?
So you can reshape your
emotions and your virtues
in ways that I think
the Confucians had
some really powerful cultural
technologies for doing.
So that's an important point.
Kahneman focuses more on how our
system one is prone to errors.
That's why I tend to,
in a corrective way,
try to emphasize how system
one's really important.
AUDIENCE: I like the
concepts, at least the words
that you put up, wu-wei and de.
I used to call it like
emotional and rational,
something much more vague.
And actually my question
was a little bit
that if you go full
emotional, full wu-wei,
you lose all rationality,
that's not ideal.
You become more like pure
instinct, more animalesque.
But on the other side,
full rational system two,
in this context,
is just too dry.
It's not a healthy way to
live and eventually grinds out
way too much.
So everyone, I guess, has
to find like their middle
in between where to use system
two, where to use system one.
And the idea is to flow
as much as possible.
But you're right
that we have to be
able to actually take one system
when intuition is just wrong.
TED SLINGERLAND: It's
also important to realize
that system one is not fixed.
System one can get reshaped
in a variety of ways.
So we're not just
stuck with a system one
that we had when we
were four-year-olds.
AUDIENCE: But I think one of
the problems is that when we
consciously try to change our
system one in ways that are
actually not natural to us, when
we try to out-force ourself--
I don't know.
It's just a comment.
I don't really have
a question about it.
TED SLINGERLAND: Yeah,
you need to work.
So that's where the Mencian--
I like the Mencian
model a lot, because he
is saying we've got to
change our system one.
We just have these sprouts.
We need to make them grow
into full-grown virtues,
but you can't force it.
He has a story
about a farmer who
goes out and pulls
on his sprouts
to try to make them grow
faster and kills them.
So you can't be like the
Mohist utilitarians who
want to pull on their sprouts.
But you also can't be lazy
and sit around and not
water or weed at all.
You've got to do something.
So the important
thing to realize
is that none of the
early Chinese thinkers
really think we're OK at birth.
Even the most radicals, so
people like Laozi, who says,
let's go back to our original
nature, he's writing this.
So the people he's talking
to are already messed up.
So they need to go back
to something that's
a kind of manufactured
nature, that he's imagining
is what our true nature is.
So I think all these things--
no one thinks that we want to
have the hot cognition we had
when we were four-year-olds.
Toddlers are not a model
of how we want to behave.
So the trick then is how
much shaping is appropriate
and how much cold
cognition is appropriate.
And that's where the splits
between, for instance,
the Taoists and
Confucians arise.
The Taoists think the Confucians
are overdoing it and turning us
into robots.
And the Confucians
think that the Taoists
are kind of lazy
children who don't
understand civilized life.
And the two play off each other.
I don't think the "Tao Te
Ching" or "The Zhuangzi"
make sense except as
kind of protest movements
against this kind of
excessive training--
what they see as
excessive training.
So there's a balance
you need to strike.
And the fact that
none of these schools
ever really wins
out in early China
suggests that there's
no right answer.
There's no right way
to get that balance.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
ways in which technology
makes the problem worse.
Do you see any ways in which
technology helps or can help?
TED SLINGERLAND: Yeah.
I'm looking forward
to self-driving cars.
I'm looking forward to a
time when you could actually
use commute time instead
of being, again, drowned
by too much
information and people
merging and worrying
about traffic,
to opening up new spaces
for daydreaming and just
looking out the window
and thinking about things.
So there could be ways
that technology can help.
Technology could also help just
by making us more efficient
when we are exerting effort,
so that we create more time
to be off.
The problem is that's not
actually what happens, right?
We're more efficient, and we
just keep doing that, right?
So if it was back in--
when I was in grad school,
you still had to write
letters to people.
So if I wanted to correspond
with a European colleague,
you'd write a letter on
that funny thin paper.
And you'd mail it, and you'd
have to wait a month or two
and come back.
Now I can email them, so
that's more efficient.
But all it means is that I now
interact with a lot more people
and I have a lot
more work to do.
So that's the problem
is that technology,
I think, in theory could help.
But it just seems to be human
nature that we overdo things,
and we tend to just
not know when to stop.
But I think that
that's something
that needs to be thought
about is how to use technology
not just to increase
our efficiency at work,
but to use that then to buy us
time to have that down time,
to allow our body and
cognition to do its thing.
AUDIENCE: So I can
personally relate
to the idea of not trying too
hard to be good at something.
And thanks for sharing that.
The one thing I thought you
didn't talk about at all
was practice.
I cannot be good at anything
just by not trying too hard
at it.
I have to practice
fairly deliberately
before I stop thinking about it,
and then I'm going to be good.
TED SLINGERLAND: Yep.
So that was kind of my point
with the life stage thing.
You can't sit down.
So if I sat down at a piano--
I don't know how
to play the piano.
If I sat down and tried to
solo, I would sound ridiculous.
It would sound stupid.
I have a brother-in-law
in Rome who's
a jazz pianist, who does that.
He'll sit down at a piano
and just noodle around.
It sounds amazing.
He has a song called
"I'll be Bach,"
where he takes Bach and
then does weird things.
He starts playing
it faster or slower.
He starts adding stuff,
puts things in the piano.
It sounds cool, but only because
he knows how to play Bach,
because he's trained his
whole life to be a musician.
So in the Butcher Ding story,
he also talks about how--
well, why can I do this?
I trained for 19
years as a butcher,
and that's why I'm
able to do that.
So that's what I mean.
None of this stuff-- it's
always against the background
of training.
And obviously in
the earlier stages
the carving and polishing
is more important.
You can't solo until you
learn how to master the thing.
I think that that's where
the corrective Taoist
strategies of forgetting
or letting go,
they're really more appropriate
once you're a trained expert.
And now what you need
to do is stop thinking.
And so there's actually--
I run through some of
the experimental evidence
that people who are good
golfers need to not think.
So if you ask them
to think about what
they're doing when
they're putting,
they overshoot the hole.
If they're a baseball player and
you have them think about what
angle are you hitting the
ball-- think about the angle
you're using when
you hit the ball--
they don't hit as
well-- professionals.
But novices do better
when they think.
So they need to pay attention.
And so obviously which
one, whether you're
focusing on trying
or not trying,
depends on where you are in
that skill development training
course of knowledge acquisition.
So you're absolutely right.
I didn't emphasize the
training thing so much.
But all of this is
against the background
of the fact that none of the
hot cognition that we value--
very little of it is inborn.
It needs to be acquired.
It needs to be trained.
But once you have
the training, you
need to know when to
let your training go.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]